hi everyone
this is professor mda science and today
i want to talk about the time evolution
operator
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics time evolution in
quantum mechanics is governed by the
schrodinger equation which tells us how
quantum states
change in time the time evolution
operator gives us an alternative way of
doing this
today we'll focus on the definition of
the time evolution operator
and in some of its most important
properties but moving forward
it will give us the tools to describe
time evolution in terms of states
through the so-called schrodinger
picture or through operators in the
so-called heisenberg picture
or through a mixture of states and
operators in the so-called interaction
picture so today's video is rather
fundamental
but it will open the doors for many
exciting new topics so let's go
time evolution in quantum mechanics is
governed by the schrodinger equation
it is given by i h bar times the
derivative with respect to time
of the state psi equal to the
hamiltonian h
acting on the state psi in this
expression the hamiltonian here is the
operator associated with the total
energy of the system
the joiner equation is a linear
homogeneous first order differential
equation in time
this means that once we've specified an
initial condition
say the state of the system at time t 0
then the solution of the joinery
equation
which here i abbreviate with the
initials s e
tells us the state of the system at any
other time t
so this is how time evolution works in
quantum mechanics
and you can learn more about it in our
video on the drawinger equation
linked in the description what i want to
do today
is to rephrase time evolution in a
somewhat different language
making use of an operator called the
time evolution operator
the key observation is that the drawing
equation is a linear equation
which implies that the correspondence
between the state at time t 0 here
and the state at time t here is linear
explicitly imagine that the state at t 0
is given by the linear superposition of
two other states
psi one of t zero and psi two of t zero
for some coefficients c one and c two
which in general are complex numbers
then the fact that the schroedinger
equation is linear means that the state
psi at time t is given by the same
linear superposition of the state psi 1
at time t and the state psi 2 at time t
we can summarize this by stating that
the correspondence between
psi of t and psi of t 0
is linear which means that we can relate
them by a linear operator
u of t t 0. the u operator is the time
evolution operator
and it depends on two variables t and t
0.
the defining equation simply says that
if we start with the state psi
of t 0 and we apply the time evolution
operator
u t t 0 on it then we obtain the state
psi
at time t in the rest of the video we'll
explore the properties of the time
evolution operator
our definition of the time evolution
operator up here is rather general
so the first thing we want to do is to
learn more about the specific form that
u takes
let's start with the simplest case when
both time arguments of the operator are
the same
so we can write psi of t 0 is equal to u
t 0 t 0 acting on psi of t 0.
as psi is an arbitrary cat then this
implies that u
t 0 t 0 is simply the identity operator
if we think about this for a moment it
makes sense if time doesn't change
then the state doesn't change either so
the time evolution operator should
simply be the identity operator
what about t different from t0 to figure
this out let's start with the schroinger
equation
we can now expand the state psi of t in
terms of the time evolution operator and
the initial state
on both the left hand side
and on the right hand side
the time dependence in this term in
brackets is now entirely captured by u
and psi of t 0 does not depend on t this
means that we can take it outside the
derivative
and then cancel it with psi of t0 on the
other side
we end up with this equation for the
time evolution operator
putting everything together we can
completely specify the operator u
t t 0 by solving this first order
differential equation we just derived
and then specifying the boundary
condition up here
next i want to rewrite this equation in
a somewhat different form that is also
used very frequently
let's start by isolating the derivative
on one side
and the rest to the other
and i have changed the name of the
variable t to t prime for reasons that
will become clear in a moment
let's now integrate both sides of this
equation with respect to t prime
and we're integrating from the initial
time t 0 to the final time t
so i want it t as the upper integration
limit here and here and this is why i
used t
prime to start with the left hand side
is now very easy to integrate
and gives u t t 0 minus
u t 0 t 0. this then equals the right
hand side which in general may be a
difficult integral
so i'll just leave it as it is
we now know that u t 0 to 0 is simply
the identity
so we end up with the time evolution
operator equal to the identity
and then this integral
so what have we accomplished from a
fundamental point of view not much
all we've done is to start with the
original differential equation and the
boundary condition that we had up here
and then rewritten them together into
this single integral equation
but in general we're not any closer to
finding a solution
so you may ask why bother the reason is
that depending on the problem at hand
one or the other expression can be more
convenient to work with so it is very
important to be aware of both
the next property i want to explore is
the application of multiple time
evolutions
let's imagine we want to go from time t
double prime
to time t mathematically we have this
equation for the time evolution of the
state psi
let's now imagine that we still go
between the same two times
but we first go from t double prime to
an intermediate time t
prime and then from t prime
to the final time t mathematically the
first step is given by this
and the second step is given by this
let's now write the last step again
we can now insert this expression for
the state at t prime
into this term and we end up with this
final expression
let's recap in both these cases the
initial time
is t double prime here and here and the
final time
is t here and here this equation
and this equation describe the same time
evolution so they must be equal
this implies that u t t double prime
is equal to u t t prime
times u t prime t double prime
this is the key result of this slide
this equation shows how we can combine
time evolutions together we can of
course
generalize this argument dividing our
time interval into n steps
which don't have to be equal and then we
can write that the time evolution
operator connecting
t1 and tn is equal to the time evolution
operator connecting
t n minus one and t n times the time
evolution operator connecting t tn minus
2
and tn minus 1 all the way to the time
evolution operator between t2 and t3
and then between t1 and t2
before we move on i want to emphasize
that this expression is general
it does not require that different times
are ordered
let's go back to the composition of just
two intervals
as up here let's consider the case when
t
is equal to t double prime we get u
t t equal to u t t
prime times u t prime t
we know that this is the identity
operator so we can write
u t t prime times u d prime t
as equal to the identity we can make a
similar argument to show that u
t prime t times u t t prime equals the
identity
and we can put these two results
together to conclude that u
t prime t is the inverse of u dt
prime so this is how we calculate the
inverse of the time evolution operator
and the result actually makes sense
the inverse operator simply corresponds
to reversing the arrow of time
the next property of the time evolution
operator that i want to prove
is that it is a unitary operator and to
do so we first need to consider an
infinitesimal time evolution
let's start again with the joining
equation
we can rewrite it as the infinitesimal
change in the state
psi equal to minus i over h-bar
times the hamiltonian acting on the
state psi all multiplied by an infinite
decimal change in time
we can also write the infinitesimal
change in the state
as the difference between the state at t
plus dt
and the state at t this is still equal
to the same expression
and we can then isolate the state at t
plus dt
to get this expression
in parallel we know that the state at
time t plus dt
is related to the state at time t by
this time evolution operator
comparing these two equations we see
that u
t plus dt t is equal to this
this operator is called the
infinitesimal time evolution operator
with this infinitesimal operator we are
now ready to prove that the time
evolution operator is a unitary operator
to do so we need to recall a result from
the video on unitary operators
if we have an operator u epsilon that is
written like this
where f is a hermitian operator and
epsilon is an infinitesimal
then such an operator is a unitary
operator
comparing this result with our
expression for the time evolution
operator here
we see that they have the same form and
this implies that the infinitesimal time
evolution operator
is a unitary operator the next step is
to build a general time evolution
operator
u dt prime by combining together a very
large number of infinitesimal time
evolution operators like this
we now know from the video on unitary
operators that the product of two
unitary operators is itself unitary
so this implies that the general time
evolution operator
is also unitary overall we can write
that for the time evolution operator
the adjoint is equal to the inverse
which in turn is equal to the time
evolution operator with the argument
reversed
remembering the key property that
unitary operators don't change the norm
of quantum states then this result makes
sense
we know that time evolution as described
by the drawing equation conserves the
norm
so we could have expected that the time
evolution operator should be unitary
so far we've introduced the time
evolution operator we've figured out the
differential equation in the base
and we've looked into some of its
properties what i want to do to finish
is to give you an example of a time
evolution operator
and the example i've picked is one we
already discussed in the video on the
schrollinger equation
i want to look at a conservative system
remember that it is a system in which
the hamiltonian does not depend on time
in a conservative system the time
derivative of the time evolution
operator
is equal to the hamiltonian acting on u
d t 0
where h is time independent
this equation can now be integrated
directly to obtain the time evolution
operator
as equal to the exponential of minus i
h times the time difference t minus t
0 all divided by h bar just to be
absolutely clear
this here is the product of the time
independent hamiltonian on the one hand
and the time difference on the other
okay so this is an explicit expression
for the time evolution operator which is
valid when we have a conservative system
it is a rather useful expression and to
see an example of why we'll prove again
something we already showed in the video
on the drawing equation
but this time around we'll use the time
evolution operator for the proof
what i want to prove is that the time
evolution in conservative systems
takes a rather simple form when working
in the energy basis
to do so let's start with the eigenvalue
equation for the hamiltonian of a
conservative system
where the e n are the eigenvalues and
the u n the eigenstates
both of which are time independent
because h is time
independent the eigenstate of the
hamiltonian form a basis of state space
so we can write a general state at time
t 0
in the energy representation like this
and as always the expansion coefficients
are given by the bracket
u n psi and again they are time
independent for a conservative system
now let's consider the state psi at a
different time t
by the definition of the time evolution
operator it is equal to u
t t 0 acting on psi at t 0.
we can plug in our expression for u as
an exponential
and we can also write out the state in
the energy basis
we can next move the exponential into
the sum here
and we end up with this
as these are the energy eigenstates then
the action of the exponential of the
hamiltonian simply gives the exponential
of the eigenvalues
and we end up with sum over n of cn
times this exponential times the
eigenstate
now what does this mean if we start at
time t
0 and our quantum state is given by this
expansion
in the energy basis then at a later time
t
our state will simply be given by the
same expansion
where each energy eigenstate has
independently evolved according to an
exponential
that depends on the corresponding energy
eigenvalue
as we discussed earlier we already
derived this result in the video on the
drawing equation
but this here shows how the time
evolution operator allows us to approach
the same problem
in an alternative but equivalent way
if we go back to our differential
equation for u up here
we've just shown that for a conservative
system
then the time evolution operator has
this simple form
at this point you may be tempted to
guess that if the hamiltonian is
time dependent then the solution would
look something like this
but is this true unfortunately
things are not so easy let's first
assume that for t
different from t prime the hamiltonians
of the system at these different times
commute in this case this expression for
u
would in fact be the correct solution
but in the most general case the
hamiltonians at different times
do not commute and then this solution
does not work
in this more general case the solution
can be written as a series
called the dyson series but we're going
to leave that for another video
so whether we study time evolution in
quantum mechanics in terms of
states or in terms of the time evolution
operator things are relatively easy for
conservative systems
but the problem becomes rather difficult
when the hamiltonian depends on time
let's recap the time evolution operator
u
is the operator that allows us to
describe the evolution of a quantum
state
from time t0 to time t
the operator obeys this differential
equation and is subject to this initial
condition
and putting these two together we can
completely specify the form of u
we've seen that we can stitch together
different time evolutions
that the inverse of the time evolution
operator is obtained by simply reversing
the arrow of time
and the time evolution operator is
unitary
this last property is very useful
because unitary transformations conserve
the norm
so time evolution as encoded by the
operator u does not change the
normalization of quantum states
as we evolve them in time finally we've
looked at the special case of
conservative systems through which the
hamiltonian is time
independent and in this case the time
evolution operator takes this
particularly simple
exponential form the time evolution
operator is a convenient way to describe
time evolution in quantum mechanics
and is complementary to what we learned
in the video on the schrolinger equation
the next steps are to explore how we can
use this operator in the so called
pictures of quantum mechanics these
include the schrodinger picture
the heisenberg picture and the
interaction picture and as always
if you liked the video please subscribe